- The fans want more,
so we're going to do something
we call "Audience Ask".
- Oh Lordy.
- Are you ready?
- Mhm.
(plucking string instrument)
- [Kelly] There ya go.
So where is Latisha?
Oh hi, Latisha.
(applause)
I heard you singin'.
- Oh, thank you!
- I know, Latisha can sing, I
heard her on commercial break.
- Oh, you can sin--
- So what do you wanna ask Lisa?
- So uh, Kelly, so nice to meet you.
Lisa nice to meet you.
Andy and Buffy, what's good?
(laughter)
So the question I had for you is;
If you had to be locked in a room
with any of the Real House Wives,
who would it be and what
would you talk about
to make the time pass?
- Wow!
- Oh my goodness!
That's not fair since I just left.
Oh, it could be from
any of the franchises.
- It could be from any of the franchises.
- Um, I think probably Bethany,
but I probably wouldn't have
to discuss anything with her
'cause I wouldn't get a word in edgewise.
Because--
(laughter)
uh, yeah.
- [Kelly] You're so mean.
- Yeah, so, probably Bethany.
- That's awesome, well thank
you Latisha (applause).
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Thank you
for warmin' it up.
- We have another question.
Here we go.
(plucking string instrument)
- Where is Brenna?
Brenna.
Hi Brenna.
(applause)
- Thank you.
So, I actually have two questions.
- Okay-- greedy, but okay.
(chuckles)
the first one is;
do you think that Stassi and Kristen
are gonna be able to mend things?
- Well, I think, fundamentally,
there's been a difference between them.
I mean, I try not to weigh in
on this too much, personally,
because I've always found
Kristen a little difficult
to get on with, myself.
But I think this year Stass has grown up--
They both have grown up, I have to say.
She's got a book deal now, Kristen.
And Stassi's, you know, getting married
and should be on the
best sellers list, so,
they're both growing up,
but I think the divide
just got wider and wider
and I don't know, but
there's years of history,
so I'm hopeful.
Because it's a shame to break
up such a long friendship.
But, I don't know, this
season it was very bumpy,
very bumpy.
- [Lisa] Fingers crossed.
- [Kelly] Drama!
- Thank you
- [Lisa] Yeah.
- [Kelly] All right.
What's the second question, greedy?
- And what do you think the deal is
with Jax unfollowing everybody?
Is he trying to stir the pot, or?
- Oh, I cannot spill that one,
because that kinda comes
at the end of the season.
- Oh, she's trying to get you to--
- Yeah, you are!
Like, who's she working for, exactly!
I can't give that away
otherwise I would be in--
but you know, Jax he's very complicated,
complicated character.
(clicks tongue)
- He sounds fun.
- He's a-- that is bad!
(laughter)